es el mayor acuerdo de libre comercio
del mundo que entró en vigor el primero
de enero la asociación económica e
integral regional conocida como rcp fue
firmada en noviembre de 2020 las
negociaciones comenzaron en 2013 abarca
la región de asia-pacífico y reúne a 15
países firmantes que representan
alrededor del 30 por ciento de la
población mundial y el 30 por ciento del
pib global esto la convierte en la
primera zona económica del mundo por
delante de eeuu y la unión europea la
rcp permite reducir los derechos de
aduana y abyss hasta el 90 por ciento de
las mercancías intercambiadas entre sus
signatarios excluyendo los llamados
productos sensibles armoniza y
simplifica las normas de transacción y
la tributación necesarias para
intensificar el comercio en la zona la
rcp podría generar un superávit de más
de 160 mil millones de dólares en 2030
para los países asiáticos este acuerdo
también refuerza el papel clave de china
en la región
pero no sólo quedan ganadores porque
india que recientemente se ha acercado a
eeuu está muy ausente de la asociación
desde entonces las relaciones entre
nueva delhi y beijing se han deteriorado
a finales de 2019 el primer ministro-
narendra modi había decidido abandonar
las negociaciones y mantenerse al margen
de la rcp sin embargo las negociaciones
pueden reanudarse sin nueva delhi lo
solicita por escrito